[Music]
good morning baby pretty what are we
doing are we going yeah the most
stressful day of the way for me I can
tell I have always had to wear many hats
in this the role of mine with JK news so
I have to reproduce which means like
[Applause]
which I also have like I have article
help from Jess and be joy and then now
more recently you and then during the
filming days though is where now you're
helping the most because I've always had
to be a showrunner and being the
showrunner when you're being ignored
it's not easy it's a very very difficult
test because everyone is the crew like
they're all really high-energy and
they're just like in their own world
lots of the time so it's a really
stressful position for me to be in
because I'm really focused on a story
there you're reporting so it's the fact
that I'm books on the story I'm focused
on trying to move the shooter long and
it's hard to move [ __ ] along and I'm so
soft-spoken or you know like everyone
just had learned to tune me out like I'm
like that okay like for parents out
there you know how your baby just cries
and cries and cries and then you end up
like learning to tune them out at some
point when they're fine and they're just
crying just to cry that's kind of how I
feel at this situation here so because I
was getting insanely overwhelmed with
that pressure of needing to handle the
articles handle the guests handle moving
the shoot alone
that's why if Casey could be help me run
the show because I can't wear it so many
hats in one day because I'm gonna lose
my mind think about three maybe four
weeks now how am i doing that you've
been helping and you have helped me a
lot
relieve relieve a lot of the stress that
I've been having during filming days
because we've been tested we were
testing out like you being a director
and like helping with the direction of
an article because these days it's
getting harder and harder to find
articles that are worth talking about
for news because we're comedy channel we
can't talk about so much sad depressing
things cuz that's mainly what the the
mainstream media likes to focus on so it
gets harder to find stories to even talk
about because of that we're like well
let's see like we can work with these
like crap your articles and maybe give a
direction like I give the cast a sort of
head space to be in
well we filmed these not-so-great
articles but then that turned out to be
really hard too because then like you
know you'll give the direction in the
beginning of the shoot or like the
filming of that article but then people
will forget and then big long tangents
and then like it just it's kind of like
all this work for nothing kind of thing
well it's a balance so like on a film
set when you're an ad which is like
assistant director which is the guy
that's you know trying to keep the show
moving along you continue this go inside
oh yeah you got a friend you can stay
here okay I have to prep the articles
and stuff so you can fill them in for
the rest of it okay but yeah so as an ad
you gotta keep the show moving along
your the schedule kinda you're the
you're the fun stock for the party
Cooper at a good conversations happening
off-camera or like cubes is having a
good time off-camera but then you got to
get camera going and being a cast member
definitely what I seen good 80s do
though is that they're able to keep the
show going and push it along without
angering people I've seen bad 80s too
bad 80s seem like they just have a stick
up their butt all the time there's like
all right people let's go cameras up
let's go thank you phones but it really
sucks the life out of the set it sucks
the life out of the the room for me I'm
trying to find the balance between you
know staying on task but keeping the fun
last week was a great improvement from
the week before so I'm assuming today
will be another great improvement from
last week
so we'll see all right it is lunchtime
now we're actually it's past lunchtime
because no one else is eating so guys
have a question for you guys how how am
i doing as a tea or director or whatever
this musician is I like it more with you
here really yeah frankly yeah sweet I
did two I really that was a lie and then
now give them the honor no no no
honestly I like the twos I think the
direction helps out cuz sometimes like
you know I think being on JK news at
least for me I'm balancing two things
one is being a comedian but then the
other is kind of being like a
storyteller and I guess an actor in a
scene and as sometimes my comedian side
turns on I'm just doing all these
one-off jokes that's not really adding
through everything but then having you
there kind of helps me put everything
back together so I'm not having like oh
just a fun fest in my brain that's not
really adding to the overall article so
I really like you I just like listening
to a man cuz I don't respect women I
also like that feels like we're all
working towards a goal yeah yeah now
instead of before we really look like
everyone was just sort of whatever true
cuz I've been a cast member to and
sometimes on this long like went near
the end of the day I always feel like
like what am I like what are we doing
here like it's just you start to get
kind of stuck in your own whatever
thoughts in your head and just don't
know what you're really trying to say
anymore yeah and even if we don't do it
perfect to what you like you pitched
like I still feel like we've worked
towards something together as a group
it's still more focused sometimes
towards the end article I can tell Joe's
having his own and one Steve's having
his own end
my own n1 and we're not playing one
basketball game my true horse is having
that direction of what okay even though
doing trick shots right yeah having that
one game or Charlie true I like it true
no because it's you and I hang with you
often and so it just feels familiar if
you're in somebody else I don't think I
would like it as much
I wouldn't respect our thoughts right
fishin is a female is it her her I like
how you have the headphones on TIFF mmm
ah nothing well we're just talking about
how it's very important to listen to the
thoughts of women and your tailor voices
serious so it must have been the
opposite of that it's the weekend
oh yes our weekend yes Thursdays after
JK muses list because it's like the most
stressful the thing that you're like
worried about the most of the week - um
and then once that's done you're like a
job well done good job time to enjoy
yourself I love it when you get all like
steezy with it like when you get yeah I
stylish with it like like I don't know
mm-hmm yes swag yeah there you go
so now we get to enjoy our Thursday
night I mean tomorrow we do have to come
back and do a JK me shoot in the morning
but it's not J key news itself it's not
to stress about it true and shakin
there's this real work I mean not I mean
I knew it was real work but now that I'm
part of the whole rotation of how of the
scheduling in life it's a lot it's good
it's grueling it's just like it's just
constant like you got to keep pushing
forward even though your brain starting
to check out from all these
conversations and we film from 9 a.m. to
7 p.m. and we just have a one-hour lunch
break in between so we pump out videos
all day and it's once a week and it's
just
gruelling like you said yeah it's like
imagine trying to have the most exciting
and insightful high and funny
conversation ever for like 12 hours
straight or 10 hours straight or however
however many are sighted yeah 10 hours
straight so see and we're so very before
you you weren't with me the whole day so
you don't know everything I went through
like all the conversations that were
head and all this stuff and like some
peas I want to tell you certain things
but then I'll tell you like honestly
I'll tell you tomorrow I can't even yeah
I felt very disconnected from you on
Thursday yeah I know because I'm just
like I can't do this
you do feel exhausted but you know it's
actually been really nice not having to
do this alone anymore and like now you
get to see and be with me the whole day
and then like we could be in on the
conversations that were ahead today
because you're sitting there and
listening in the whole time too so I
think for me personally I feel more
connected to you in our relationship now
that you've been really interesting I
definitely do so like because we we blog
together we know we raise Isaac together
we have a life together and so I was
like oh I'll eat Thursdays and Tuesday's
we can have our breaks from each other
you know it's good to spend some time
apart as well but now that I can feel
this I'm like comparing the two I'm like
dude I so I rather work with you every
single day be with you every single
moment I was about to say like maybe not
party maybe not party maybe not party
because party gets intense and it's
competitive oh boy we would probably
fight on Tuesdays that we had to
together well it's a good game a time
party there that's another thing so I
think this is a perfect blend and and
yeah I like your involvement with views
isn't like a competitive sense where we
need to play a key like a board game
chess board games get intense and we
take them we know we get a very
competitive we take it serious huh
sometimes I hate the bleep bleeps are
always louder than the audio and it's
just like sorry you were like really the
backwards it no I tell him to cut out
the bad works you just like our entire
last sentence and just add random bleeps
to it I'm not married to that guy he's
such a troll it would go crazy okay
aren't you supposed to be studying
yeah it's your fault you push the camera
in my face you're distracting me it was
I was just I was getting b-roll Casey
got a camera guy he got a light guy he
got a sound guy here I think he's like
hey I'm supposed to be doing I know how
to make Casey cut he's just gonna cut
[Music]
[Music]